so I heard that you now have I want you
to have food in your mouth when I ask
this next question I heard that you now
have a bad habit when you're out with
your kids what is it oh oh in my mouth
what's wrong with your mouth that's not
a sentence you're here today
I swear a lot oh me too I have a filthy
milk me too look waitress thank you
right yeah
I I was awake look people they make you
mad and darn it doesn't cover it yeah
like yeah not in this town yeah what is
your do you have a rule with your kids
though
well it's morphed over the years so my
kids are almost eight and just turned
five like I tried the swear jar for a
while oh my God that's gonna get rich
and filled up so fast yeah that I was
just using it to like tip any delivery
person that came to the house this is
not what the swear jar is for yeah or it
was like you know Tooth Fairy money yeah
and so I realized all right that's not
gonna work it's not the deterrent that I
need what really sort of brought it home
is uh I was driving with my son Conrad
and someone ran out in front of the car
and I screamed like oh my God you bleep
and bleep yeah and then everything was
fine I kept on driving and I hear this
little voice from the back of data
what's a bleep and bleep oh and I was
like oh don't tell Mommy yeah don't tell
Madness or something you know Daddy got
angry and he's like oh okay and then
maybe two days later the exact same
thing happened again someone like
someone on a bike went right in front of
the car oh my God the exact same exploit
is you believe
and then Conrad again it's like um gotta
there's those words again I'm like yeah
son yeah I'm really really sorry about
that then maybe a week later I'm outside
of the grill I'm having a good time I'm
grilling up some food and our younger
son was was uh an infant and my wife
comes out and she's tired and she's
bouncing the baby she's like I just want
you to know what your son said he what
he said I want to kiss my baby brother I
want to kiss that bleep and bleep
[Applause]
that's when you go where did he hear
them
at school these days so I've had to rein
it back in a little bit and now my kids
think it's a joke they're like you're
doing it again Dad okay tell us a
sentence look I tell my kids that they
can curse when they pay their bills you
have to earn being this trashy
I was like
do whatever you want be as class as if
you want when you're older but like
right now you can't do yeah cause I'm
like
every now and then I'll slip up and then
they'll be like oh and I'm like no no no
no don't even talk about it my daughter
has no hope coming from theater she's
got a right potty mouth for a mother
terrible yeah but they need to see all
sides yeah I'm just trying to show you
all sizes
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you